I mean if you were going to start an
underage sex trafficking ring a court
great advice for you hi I'm Michael
Moynihan for reason TV and today we are
here with Mike Flynn the editor-in-chief
of big government com Mike you've made a
bit of a splash recently with a series
of videos about acorn give our viewers
who haven't seen these ubiquitous videos
while there Eddie what what's on the
videos and and then how you obtained
them right real quick the videos kind of
relay the saga if you will of two
filmmakers activists James O'Keefe and
henna Giles who go to a number of acorn
offices posing as a pimp and a
prostitute and they are seeking acorns
assistance to get a grant or a loan for
a house to run a brothel out of and in
the course of the interview they also
reveal that that this brothel will not
only house Hannah Giles and her
operation but also a dozen underage El
Salvadoran immigrants who will also be
turning tricks and amazingly enough you
know so far we've shown videos from six
different offices and in all six the
Acorn employees went along with it
didn't question it and also we're
extraordinarily helpful in trying to
find ways to make this work for the
Pippin the prostitute what's its
connection to the administration well I
Barack Obama the one job he's had
outside of government is as a community
organizer and worked very closely with
acorn it we are going to be telling the
story probably in the next week about
how community organizing was done in
Chicago with acorn SEIU Barack Obama and
Jeremiah Wright and it's it's a pretty
rich story that includes a scene in
which a corn true story clogged up
emergency rooms to stop Amy Lutz's from
coming there because they're trying to
unionize the hospital why does the
average person care if there is an
institutional problem at a place like a
clerk Oh acorn what has
large role to play in the housing
debacle we just went through you know
they had a very very refined business of
shaking down banks and financial
institutions and four and getting them
through coercion to get them to make
loans to risky borrowers I'm not saying
they're totally responsible for the
housing meltdown but they have a role to
play in that they also you know we we
have one consequence of the journalism
we've done on this is we now have in our
possession a lot of internal acorn
documents of come from whistleblowers
and one thing that's really interesting
is we have and will release this soon a
handbook for how they organize and do
community organizing and it's a really
revealing documents fascinating let me
pick up a criticism from a corner who
says that you know you guys were kicked
out of some offices or not you guys but
the two did made the videos you say
that's not true no we will before this
is all over you will see video from
every office that James johana went to
we release the videos in a very
deliberate way as you know I mean we
kind of rolled them out slowly we first
were with Baltimore and then with DC and
immediately after that acorn put out a
statement that said we were kicked out
of New York out of La kicked out of
Philadelphia kicked out of San Diego
kicked out of miami on monday be
released in new york so that was a lot
later that week we released San Diego
but that was a lie they have put a lot
of stock in the fact we were kicked out
of Philadelphia but we just released a
video yesterday which shows we are not
kicked out of Philadelphia the a court
employee there was trying to help James
and Hannah so you know we will show
every video of every office that they
they went to and we'll let the facts
speak for themselves you know by any
objective standards this is this is a
pretty big story how did the media react
and who got it right who got it wrong
Jon Stewart Jay Leno got it right what's
remarkable is how unfazed the Acorn
people are by this question in situation
this is clearly not the first time
they've been hearing this oh you're
processing a pimp you like to work
through the tax implications of said
relationship hey Tonya get me form seven
days
in South Park and so I would like to see
if there are any housing loan
opportunities for some of my employees
and also what kind of corporate tracks I
should be failing under and exactly what
kind of business are you running
education company and the big media
mostly got it wrong you know the media
initially totally ignored the story and
it was really you could almost if you
did a timeline it was after Jon Stewart
waited that the media started away it
and was very fine and with you saw I was
like within the first two days of the
videos coming out Jon Stewart to the
phenomenal piece that he totally got
what was wrong with this scenario and he
also called out the media for ignoring
it well this is an impressive expose I
would love to know the intrepid
journalist who broke this story 60
minutes the AP that guy who gets the
Predators your dumbness telling the
whole world you're not a pimp you're
just playing one on our show I'm one of
the money and you played it on those
tapes yeah one of the way this guy's
ever are you kidding babe where were the
real reporters on this story you know
what investigative media give me a
camera three where the hell were you and
when the media finally got around to the
story the first thing they tried to do
was attack Andrew Breitbart James and
Hannah do you also see this as a kind of
a morality tale with media coverage and
in what stories the media covers and and
is it is it an example of bias I mean is
that seriously I mean you know here you
have on video I mean just just try to
think of the hypothetical situation in
which an office in six so far different
offices branch offices organization
provides advice for trafficking in
underage girls sex trafficking the idea
that members of the media would try to
defend that or ignore it because of that
organizations politics is pretty
disturbing I mean I'll think of any
company if you went into six different
starbucks and asked the managers you
know I've got some people I want to
smuggle in can you help me you know
there would be protests outside of every
Starbucks as there should be
legitimately the thing that I find
really frankly disturbing is that when
you look at these videos the employees
do not even Blanche they don't
flinch and they provide really helpful
advice I mean if you were going to start
an underage sex trafficking ring a court
got great advice for you you know so you
it begs the question what are they here
every day what are they here on a daily
basis that they don't even recoil from
this kind of tail are you sitting on
other material is this is this a one-off
deal or you going to keep on making
splashes what's basically what's coming
up next well I mean I hopefully will
keep on making splashes I mean I guess
unfortunately there's a lot of stories
to tell right now we do have more videos
those will be released at the
appropriate time how many that we have
more yeah we you know part of this up
the design of our strategy for rolling
out is frankly to deny acorn information
we're going to tell the saiu story we're
going to tell the story of the scam
that's going on on the public right now
that a cornice said they're going to do
an internal review on their own and
they've appointed people like John
Podesta and Eastern to oversee this
internal review I mean this is like
having the Fox do an audit of the
henhouse I mean it's like ridiculous so
I mean tho those are some stories to
tell I mean and you know we one of the
great benefits of the splash we've made
is that lots of people are coming
forward with lots of stories
unfortunately there is corruption and
the intrusion of big government
everywhere both of the local state and
federal level and we're going to be
telling those stories Mike hey Michael
thanks very much thanks for coming back
to reason for reason TV on Michael
Moynihan
you